here with reaction fox news contributor
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich you know he does represent
very well i think this new he's endorsed
by aoc endorsed by the squad he's
endorsed by bernie bernie endorsed him
abortion with no restrictions whatsoever
and fracking and energy production so he
really does fit in with the climate
alarmist cults he's he's like the poster
child for them
well i mean if you really look at his
positions he is probably more radical
than almost any democrat in the senate
right now
because he's even more radical than
bernie sanders he's kind of like the
next generation of radicalism but if you
watch his campaign you'll see something
you're going to see all over the country
none of these people
can defend their record
none of them can defend joe biden nbc
news reported this morning that he is
the most unpopular president in 80 years
more than three out of four americans
believe we're on the wrong track and so
guys you know who have done nothing
their whole life except politics and
that's what fetterman is he's a career
politician who's never done anything in
the private sector that mattered has no
understanding of it
he's got to play games he's got to dance
around dr oz he's got to try to find
gimmicks because if he gets pinned as
you just did to his real record
he's gone it's hopeless
uh pennsylvanians aren't going to vote
to legalize heroin they're not going to
vote to destroy western pennsylvania's
energy industry by the way fourth
biggest energy producer in the united
states is pennsylvania they're not going
to vote for somebody who keeps releasing
murderers rapists armed robbers uh at a
time when they already have a crime wave
so on every real issue i think fetterman
has a problem but he's typical of what
we're seeing around the country uh in
georgie of warnock who has voted
overwhelmingly i think 98 of the time
with joe biden at a time when in georgia
biden's down in the low 30s and if it
becomes a warnock biden vote uh warnock
doesn't have a chance of coming back to
you know the same thing with kelly in
arizona you know they've had over 1800
opioid deaths they've had
hundreds of thousands of people cross
the border does kelly fight to get more
border agents no he votes for 87 000 new
irs agents
to control us the american people not
any extra border agents to control
illegal immigrants so kelly trying to
defend that in a state that's overrun
with the consequence of legal limits
you're seeing this in race after race
around the country the democrats cannot
debate the issues they cannot defend
their votes so they try gimmicks to try
to keep the republicans off balance
but go through this
no restrictions at all or limits on
abortion a complete moratorium in
pennsylvania on fracking this is
insanity sanctuary cities he supports
that policy he supported biden's 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus he supported
the mansion schumer deal uh he chases an
innocent man and minority down the block
and puts a shotgun in this innocent
guy's face tell me one republican that
would would ever do such a thing and and
not have the scrutiny that that deserves
well it's kind of amazing that barack
obama who was very sensitive about these
issues four or five years ago has never
said anything about fetterman as you
point out he had a shotgun and he held
this guy with a shotgun until the police
came and then it turned out the guy was
an innocent jogger out exercising
so it's kind of weird but i think it
goes deeper than that what you have
today
outside of maybe the university of
pennsylvania faculty uh you having
fetterman somebody so radical that
he can't possibly represent the people
of pennsylvania
and i think that's what makes all of
this dangerous we just saw this in
wyoming where liz cheney was repudiated
getting only 29 percent of the vote
and i think that's because you have this
growing gap i i suspect when the average
pennsylvanian looks at dr oz's real
record looks at fetterman's real record
and asks themselves which person is
going to fight for pennsylvania in the
u.s senate
i have a hunch that oz is going to win a
surprisingly big victory because there's
no evidence that fetterman other than
being for legalization of marijuana and
heroin and setting up drug centers
around the country cities paid for by
the taxpayers so you can go get your
shot from a government employee in a
nice safe space if you're a heroin
addict um
i think other people are going to look
at that stuff and say that's not us and
that's sure not the future of
pennsylvania i want to live in
and you can see in the polling now that
oz has now narrowed it in the trafalgar
poll uh you see for example that adam
laxalt is now up you see that jd vance
is now up and things are changing
dramatically and uh we'll follow it all
uh although i'll never catch up with you
i think more money was raised when you
were speaker because with democrats
using your name then i'll ever i'll
never be able to catch up in five
lifetimes mr speaker thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else